it's the left that decided that woman is
a dirty word it's the left that decided
we needed to toss out basic biology and
basic grammar along with it we didn't
want to leave you hanging with no good
news so here's something positive that
happened good afternoon and thank you
all for joining us it's great to stand
up here with some of the most
influential and amazing women from
across our state we are all here to say
frankly that we've had a enough enough
trying to erase women and girls enough
denying our biological differences from
men and enough of the craziness that is
taking over our country I've had the
honor of being both the first woman and
the first mother to serve as the
governor of Arkansas before that I was
the first mother and only the third
woman to serve as the White House Press
Secretary because of that I came into
this role with a few pretty unique
experiences among them is giving birth
to three amazing kids that experience
underscored to me that a woman's
perspective is important and
fundamentally different from a man's
nowadays though only conservatives seem
to be making that point on the left
women have taken a backseat to political
correctness it's why Senator Irving and
representative Barker had to pass the
fairness and women's sports act to
defend our girl across the state they're
using nonsense words to erase women and
girls and more importantly to erase our
voices and our experiences today we're
taking a stand against woke nonsense but
frankly started as a fad among a few
grad students has seeped down into
corporations the health care industry
and increasingly state government it's
demeaning to women and it needs to stop
in a moment I'll sign an executive order
Banning a number of all sorts of
ridiculous words from state government
documents those include words like
pregnant people laboring person
birthgiver and several other nonsense
terms that have cropped up in recent
years some on the left will accuse us of
being nitpicky that Arkansas should just
lay down and accept the cultural
revolution without complaint I say it's
the exact opposite it's the left that
decided that woman is a dirty word it's
the left that decided we needed to toss
out basic biology and basic grammar
along with it I think they're just mad
that conservatives are starting to fight
back and they better get ready because
we're just getting started thank you for
being here and thank you to the amazing
women that are standing up here with me
I'll sign this executive order we'll
hear a few words from Dr Chandler and
I'll be happy to take a few questions
thank
you